here's my plan to dismantle the Deep
State and reclaim our democracy from
Washington corruption remember he's a
former president the idea now of oh I'm
I'm an outsider and dude you were the
president of the United States how are
you an outsider of any kind once and for
all and Corruption it is
first I will immediately reissue my 2020
executive order restoring the
president's authority to remove Rogue
bureaucrats and I will wield that power
very aggressively remember what that is
is about being able to fire
government employees who are outside the
immediate political realm like secretary
of state right new president comes in
you replace the Secretary of State but
what Trump wants because he believes
that every random employee of the state
department or at least I'm sorry of the
federal government uh including the
state department and others is against
him he wants to be able to come in and
just say fire tens of thousands of
people